بدايه الفن التشكيلي اي فنان يبدا بتعلم
كيف يستخدم ادواته كيف يبدا
بالرصاص والفحم ثم الالوان ثم لازم يجب ان
يكون لديه اسلوب يتفرد به
المراه كعنصر اساسي دائما في اللوحاتي
تمثل التراث انا كثير يعني مهتمه بالتراث
والموروث الشعبي تحديدا بالسعودي لو
سالتني لماذا
صراحه خلال شفراتي تقريبا ب 2008 سافرت
الى احدى الدول الخليجيه
وزرتها هناك متحف بالمتحف ورايت اهتمام
كثير بالموروث طبعا انا بالمنطقه الشرقيه
وكما تعلم
الجزيره العربيه كبيره
ومرت بها حضارات كثيره
تقريبا تشمل يعني المنطقه العربيه من
العراق شمالا الى جنوبا عمان
منطقه حضاريه واحده
فتتشابه كثير
وجدتهم يهتمون كثيرا بالتراث والموروث نفس
اللي لدينا لكننا مهتمين فيه ومتمسكين فيه
يعني ما استني شيء من الغيره غير مرضي
نقول شيء تفتقدين وانت على الصعيد الشخصي
ولا شلون
لانه لم يكن هناك توفيق لهذا الشيء موجود
لكن لو ليس له توثيق بالعكس من الدول
الاخرى هذا طبعا الكلام كان في 2008 2009
فعندما بدات ابحث عن اسلوب خاص فيني وجدت
نفسي لا شعوريا نتجه لراسم المراه
والحليها
انتبهت الى انني قاعده ولا شعوريا قاعده
اوثق الموروث